well III hasn't started quite yet but
Google's already got the cat out of the
bag for its stadia service / controller
I don't know if you can't really talk
about all this more thing it's coming in
November we learned about the release
date we learned about who can get in and
what it's gonna cost
I don't know Stan what's your reaction
so far um mix I'm excited I think I
think they did the smart thing and led
with baldur's gate in outside after Phil
Harrison's kind of like eh on it
it's a huge announcement it's a massive
announcement and it's the thing that
it's kind of like flowing to the front
of my mind when I think about stadia
right now which i think is a smart thing
for them to do but just behind that is a
bunch of questions my biggest one is
where was all of those features that
they mentioned during GDC you're talking
like handing off from like you know one
device to another you're like starting a
game from you - yeah pausing like
sharing save files with other people you
can jump in and out and and it seems
like that's their vision for it but the
fact that they kind of sidestep that
stuff entirely and didn't make it clear
what its gonna be capable of on day one
it's something that leaves me kind of
questioning what I'm gonna be paying for
because that's the stuff that you really
want right that's the stuff do you want
you want to experience is that's the
thing that people look at and go that
could be the future like yes I do agree
with that I think you know for me I was
expecting them to sort of say like okay
you gave us all the technical BS last
time you sort of what are we actually
gonna play win and how we're gonna do
that so I obviously they accomplished
that stuff today I'm not as skeptical as
you I think like that stuff will still
be functional I'll come to a degree but
you know my bigger question is like look
this all sounds great but how are we
ever going to know if this is really
worth the cost worth the excitement
until we really try it yeah in our own
environment I mean yeah we're gonna see
it at e3 we saw it in GDC but that's not
where I play video games yeah all of
this stuff is dependent on the Internet
to work and all of that is a degree
removed from Google itself yeah you know
normally you have a console you just
know a publisher says gonna work you
assume the game's gonna function fine
here we're kind of just like yeah this
all sounds great but we're never gonna
know until you try
and because of the limited kind of roll
out of it it's gonna be kind of tricky
to even get a semblance of what that's
gonna be like for you personally because
they have that weird like you have to
invest in a founders pack and and like
limited and as far as we know like it's
only available through the Google store
you're not planning they haven't
mentioned any plans to kind of like
every tailor his retailers or anything
like that like it's really really like
you said it's it's there's a lot of
questions about will it work for me
right well I mean let's also consider
that the founders Edition is sort of
like buying something from Google to get
started early
but once the base version of stadia is
available you can bring your own
controller you don't actually have to
buy anything other than the software
you're using yeah and if you use it like
through your browser or you I think if
you have an existing probably need the
chromecast all traction yeah you need
you need to buy that at the very least
yeah yeah I think that's kind of how I
see this thing is like there's two
stages right now and if people are gonna
be paying to sort of like test all this
for Google yeah it's interesting like
they did that test with the size of
Crete last year which was nice I'd like
to see more of that happen before the
founders edition yeah I think they
should set up some sort of like we have
this maybe even make that project stream
thing available more widely and say like
his his it has you know impassionate
days where they had like a war chocolate
and graphics cards would have like
benchmark tests they should have like
some similar benchmark test for stadia
and make it freely available like try
and run this if it works you're kind of
in this position to place the idea well
yeah I mean what do they say 35 megabits
down in order to support this yeah which
is like just under five megabytes which
I think will be attainable for most
people's internet these days but this
question still questions about like you
know how does playing multiplayer at the
same time as streaming it affect your
kind of bandwidth and well so but no
multiplayer though that's all
server-side that's got nothing to do
with like the internet connection
necessarily I can see the latency being
yeah exactly that's right yeah and maybe
that's that's universal to single player
or or player I think actually
multiplayer would be better all things
considered running all locally yeah
rather than versus on disparate machines
yeah obviously we still have a lot of
questions I don't know if we're gonna
learn much more at e3
yeah I don't foresee them coming I mean
I'm not from Google itself perhaps we
can when we're talking to publishers and
and you know game developers they'll
provide more insight into that but I
think Google has has said their piece
now for the for the show but yeah it's
exciting I'm impressed with the
diversity of games that they have like
they've got a fighting game which they
have many fighting yes there's one more
in there too but yeah I mean Capcom's
apparently one of the publishers they're
supporting it okay and they do have a PC
version of 3:45 whether they put that
out there who knows but like it makes
sense for them or like that's good we've
got destiny is going to be included in
the finest pack and if you get the pro
package you get that for a limited
period with the new thing so there's
that there's various other companies and
developers that have signed up to
support either way of these it's
exciting a lot of these games are games
we already know about of course there's
a ton of new games and potentially even
new hardware the Microsoft hinted at
last year's e3 so be sure to stay tuned
to games for all that news
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]